الزراعة هناك المزيد؟ اذ ان
المساحة المقدرة الصالحة في ارض
فتنهم وسمومهم بينكم? العرب
كانوا هم السباق في كل العلوم في
يصحو العرب من غفلتهم. والى ذلك
الحين من غير المعلوم كيف يكون
ويكتشفوا الدول والمناطق التي
يدعي الغرب انهم اكتشفوها. العرب
للدولة. وستعيش الدولة رفاهية
تجعلها قبلة للزائرين والسياح
وما ادراك ما العرب? فهل حان
الوقت ليتوحد العرب? هل حان
فهل يدرك العرب ما الذي
سيستفيدونه من الوحدة والدولة
على السياحة. اذا اين تكمن
المشكلة ايها العرب. الا تعلم ان
الوقت ليكون هناك دولة عربية
واحدة? نعم سيحدث ذلك ولكن عندما
حول العالم. والسياحة هي ايضا
جزء مهم يحقق دخلا جيدا للدول
العربية الواحدة اكتفاء ذاتي لم
يسبق له مثيل الا قبل الف
الفلك والرياضيات والفيزياء.
وكانوا اول من يجوب انحاء العالم
الواحدة؟ هل يعي العرب اضرار
الفرقة وتشتت الدول في مجال
كيلومتر مربع اي نصف المساحة
التي يمكن ان تزرع في الدولة
العربية الواحدة. هذا سيحقق دخلا
مهولا بجانب الاكتفاء الذاتي
دولة واحدة تعني ان يحسب الغرب
الف حساب لكم قبل ان يحاولوا نشر
العربية قبل حتى ان تتوحد في
دولة واحدة فمصر واليمن
سبعمائة وستون مليون طن من
الحبوب. وثلاثمائة وسبعون مليون
والامارات دليل واضح على ذلك
والاردن التي تعتمد بشكل رئيسي
يعادل رأس من البقر ورأس من
الماشية لكل فرد في الدولة
الصالحة للزراعة في السودان فقط.
فماذا لو تم زراعة ثلاثمائة الف
وهي كمية كافية لتغطية احتياجات
الكرة الارضية باكملها بشكل
رأس من البقر واربعمائة وعشرة
ملايين رأس من الماشية. وهذا ما
سيكون عدد الطائرات الحربية اكثر
قليلا من تسعة الاف طائرة
العرب تزيد عن ستمائة الف كيلو
متر مربع. ونحن ذكرنا الاراضي
وثلاثمائة وثلاثة واربعين عاما
في عهد الخليفة عمر بن عبدالعزيز
مستمر لانها طاقة متجددة. وفي
المجال الزراعي. ان تم استغلال
الهدف الاول لهم هو صنع سلاح
الردع النووي. ولن يكون هذا
وثمانية عشر الف دبابة وتسعة
الاف طائرة مروحية وواحدا وخمسين
اقتصاديا. مجموع الدخل القومي
سيكون اكثر من ست تريليونات
النووي في عهد صدام وكذلك مصر
وليبيا الى ان اوقفت المعاهدة
اربعة وثمانين الف هكتار في
السودان فقط في الزراعة. لنتج
هذا فحسب بل سيكون الجيش الاكبر
في كل الازمنة عبر التاريخ.
نسبة انتاج الدولة العربية
الموحدة من النفط اثنين وثلاثين
في المائة من الانتاج العالمي.
اما في مجال انتاج الكهرباء.
وسيمتلك هذا الجيش اضخم ترسانة
سلاح امتلكها جيش غاية الان حيث
الصين والهند وقبل الولايات
المتحدة الامريكية وروسيا.
الامر جديدا عليهم فقد سبق
للعراق ان بدأ في مجال السلاح
العسكري سيتشكل جيش واحد من كل
الجيوش العربية الحالية وسيكون
طارق جميع هذه المضائق خصوصا
مضيق باب المندب وقناة السويس
العدد اربعة ملايين عسكري. وهذا
ما يشكل اكبر جيش ليس في زماننا
اضافة الى شبكات ضخمة من
الصواريخ الباليستية وغيرها.
الغربية والا لكانتا في نادي
الدول النووية. اما في المجال
الف الية عسكرية من احدث الاليات
العسكرية الموجودة في العالم
تحت ظل دولة واحدة. سيكون عدد
سكان الدولة العربية الجديدة
عسكريا. تبرز القوة النووية في
المقدمة فعند توحد العرب سيكون
دخلا هائلا منها سيعود بالفائدة
على جميع المناطق في الدولة.
الكهرباء من الطاقة الشمسية اذ
سيولد عشرين مليون من الكهرباء
دولار اي في المرتبة الثالثة
عالميا بعد الولايات المتحدة
فيكفي استغلال ثمانية بالمائة
فقط من الصحراء الليبية لانتاج
والصين متجاوزا روسيا الاتحادية.
في مجال انتاج النفط فقط ستكون
ستنقلب الاية حينها. لو كان
العرب دولة واحدة لن يظل المحتل
وسينتهي القتال في وسيعود اليمن
سعيدا كما كان دول المغرب العربي
واحدة. ستكون مساحة الدولة
العربية الواحد ثلاثة عشر مليون
كيلومتر مربع. وهذا يعني انها
ستكون في المرتبة الثانية بعد
ليطلبوا ود العرب وان تكون
الدولة العربية المكان الذي
في الوقت الحالي حيث يذهب العرب
الى الغرب لتحسين دخلهم اذ
الاسرائيلي يوما واحدا في فلسطين
ولن يعبث الاجانب بالعراق
فيها من الخارج. لو اتيح للعرب
اليوم ان يتوحدوا في دولة واحدة
ستتحكم بالتجارة العالمية.
وستحقق الدولة العربية الموحدة
وهنا نتحدث عن رفاهية اقتصادية
تتوزع بين جميع الاقطار العربية
مضائق حيوية جدا كمضيق هرمز وباب
المندب وقناة السويس ومضيق جبل
اربعمائة وعشرة نسمة اي في
المرتبة الثالثة عالميا بعد
سينتج عن ذلك مباشرة قوة جغرافية
بشرية عسكرية واقتصادية. جغرافية
ستنسى الخلافات التي بينها
وستنظر لمن يحاول اشعال الفتنة
والبحر الاحمر والمحيط الهندي
والمحيط الاطلسي. وستتحكم في
تعني القوة وتعني الثراء وتعني
السيادة وتعني ان ياتي الغرب
البحرية في العالم. حيث ستطل هذه
الدولة على سواحل البحر المتوسط
اثيوبيا. ولن يستطيع احد
ايقافهم. دولة عربية واحدة موحدة
روسيا عالميا. وتمتد سواحلها على
اهم البحار والمحيطات والمنافذ
يغترب فيه الاجانب ليبحثوا عن
مصدر جيد لارزاقهم بعكس ما يحدث
العربي فطوره في المغرب او
الجزائر او موريتانيا في اقصى
والعصر في القاهرة والمغرب في
البحرين والعشاء في اليمن. لن
العربي في سوريا ليصلي الفجر في
الاقصى ويصلي الظهر في مكة
ليبيا. وحينها فقط سينتقل العربي
من لبنان ليقوم بجولة بسيارته
العراق. وسيتنزه العربي في تونس
الخضراء ويخوض مغامراته في صحراء
ليس هناك تأشيرات دخول للعرب الى
اي منطقة في الدولة عربي. سيتوضأ
بين الكويت وقطر. حينها سيساعد
العرب مصر في ضرب سد النهضة في
في دولة حقا. وماذا لو امتلك
العرب جيشا واحدا? دولة عربية
افريقيا ثم يعود ليأخذ غداءه في
مصر بينما يستطيع ان يتناول في
واحدة. هو حلم صعب المنال. لكنه
ليس بالمستحيل. فعندما يتوحد
قتال على المناطق والاراضي بحجة
انها تابعة لهذه الدولة او تلك
يسأل العربي من اي دولة انت? بل
هل انت عربي ام اجنبي. سيتناول
الجميل. ذلك هو حلم العرب. فماذا
لو توحدت الدول العربية جميعها
العرب لن تكون هناك حدود بين
الدول العربية. ولن يكون هناك
سيمتلك العرب سلاحا نويا لا مثيل
له. وهناك سيكون العرب قوة يرغب
بعكس الوضع حاليا وعندها ستتحرر
فلسطين وتطمئن العراق وستتفق
العرب اذ لا يوجد سوى دولة
واحدة. اما ان للعرب ان ينبذوا
الغرب بالتحالف وعندها سيأتي
الغرب ليعمل في الدولة العربية
الغرب وراء ظهورهم. اما ان للعرب
ان يتوحدوا وفي الدولة الواحدة
المغرب والجزائر ولن يضطر
مواطنوها للذهاب بعيدا عنها
بين الدول. وحيث لا يدعم الغرب
هذا الطرف او ذاك ليحدث قتال بين
ليبحثوا مصدرا جيدا لارزاقهم
وسيعود اليمن وسوريا الى الزمن
الواحدة حيث يمر العربي ارجاء
الدولة ببطاقة واحدة ولا حدود
الواحدة بحسب توقعاتنا وتوقعات
الكثير من الخبراء. في الدولة
واياكم في رحلة هذا الحلم الرائع
لنعرف النتائج في دولة العرب
خيالا او احلاما وردية. لكن
دعونا نتخيل ونحلم قليلا لنرى
كيف ستكون النتائج؟ وما الذي
سيحدث عندها؟ دعوني انطلق انا
حال العرب.
ماذا لو توحد العرب في دولة
واحدة؟ قد تبدو لكم هذه الفكرة